[Music]
at reading university's atmospheric
observatory they have been measuring the
temperature every day at 10 am since
1908.
there are few places better equipped to
track what's happening as climate change
drives increasingly frequent and severe
heat events and then there's also
another one over there researcher chloe
brimacom tells me that rising baseline
temperatures are magnifying the
intensity of heat waves with trapped
high pressure air and drier hotter
ground
driving a feedback loop that acts like
an oven
by 2050 we can expect to see
temperatures above 35 degrees celsius
every year in the uk during the summer
and that also means that on current
projections sadly five thousand to seven
thousand people could lose their lives
by end of century every year because of
the heat just because of the heat in
this country in this country
and the serious health risks aren't the
only problem as transport hubs like
reading train station know only too well
extraordinary heat is an extremely
disruptive force in places that aren't
set up to cope with it and in particular
it impacts buildings and infrastructure
so in these kind of temperatures for
example roads can melt and train lines
can buckle
in fact network rail says exactly this
has happened near vauxhall train station
in london
for now though passengers all over the
country are just trying to keep going
it's actually true what they said you do
i always think it's under
underplayed but uh yeah i'll be all
right but you're struggling a bit right
now i am strictly did the bus that was
hot
yeah it was was there no air
conditioning on the bus no i was
thinking to myself actually they're
going to have to start designing them
with aren't they because we're going to
get hotter and hotter to those who study
heat and its effects
what's happening in the uk is
unprecedented but not a surprise britain
has got to stop thinking of itself as a
cold country and realize that during the
summer we are a hot country and we have
to take adequate precautions the
government simply has not taken the
warning seriously enough and prepared
adapting to the changes that are already
here requires massive investment
alongside all the money already
committed to reducing carbon emissions
but both must happen to limit the
suffering inflicted by heat
hannah thomas peter sky news